it's easy to forget
that only 10 days ago
the prime minister was dreaming of a
third term
mr speaker
you know
it's often said that a week is a long
time in politics but it turns out that
10 days is truly a lifetime because
let's face it it's a minor miracle that
the prime minister has even made it
through to
prime minister's questions and he really
ought to see the faces behind him
because prime minister it really is over
the prime minister is desperately
clinging on to his own fantasy but the
public can't afford to put up with this
farce of a government a minute longer
today
we should be talking about the tory cost
of living crisis soaring inflation and
the growing cost of brexit
but instead
it's always
it's always about him
how many more ministers
need to quit
before he finally picks up his pen
and writes his own resignation letter
perhaps that's what he's doing now
actually actually mr speaker i was just
jotting down some notes on it on his
question which i thought was uh
excellent when he was talking about the
economy uh because that is the issue
that is the country uh faces and that is
the and that is where this government is
introducing i think the most important
switch helping countries are helping uh
families up and down the country uh with
1200 pounds uh going into their bank
accounts uh right now cutting taxes for
30 million people 330 pound tax cut and
helping half a million people into work
through the way to work scheme that is a
fantastic thing to be getting on and
doing that is the priority of this
government and that's what i'm going to
focus on i'm glad he i'm glad he likes
it
in blackfoot my goodness
nothing to see we should all move on if
we live in the world
prime minister you know a few weeks ago
i compared the prime minister to monty
python's black knight
actually turns out i was wrong he's
actually the dead pirate
whether he knows it or not he's now an
ex-prime minister
he will leave behind two deeply damaging
legacies
i hope the dishonesty of his leadership
follows him out of the downing street
door but the other legacy is that of
brexit
and that will stay
because i'm sad to say
that the labour party now fully supports
mr speaker
scotland wants a different future
not just a different prime minister
so if the prime minister won't resign
will he call a general election and
allows scotland the choice of an
independent future
free from the control of westminster
[Applause]